hey guys there's a ton of skincare
information out there in the world now
fortunately there's also a lot of lies
times are changing and men are starting
to take better care of their skin every
day which is awesome so I want to warn
you against five skincare myths but most
guys still believe let's get to it
[Music]
hey guys this is your first time here on
my channel welcome I'm Daniel and so
they're subscribing also clicking that
notification belt so you won't miss any
of the next videos now let's start with
the first myth
[Music]
some people say that you should choose
your skincare products based on your age
is that true is that a myth
that's a myth guys there's a lot of
skincare products out there that claims
to be for a specific age but age is not
a skin type so it's only a sneaky
marketing move bolder men can also have
the same skin care concerns and also
skin types
then younger guys I mean it's like your
diet if foods gonna be healthy for you
when you're young it's also gonna be
healthy for you when you're older just
use the right skin care products for
your skin type whether it's dry normal
or oily skin but remember being good to
your skin because you'll wear it every
day for the rest of your life
another myth some people say hey if
you're young and in your teens don't
worry about your pimples or acne because
you'll eventually outgrow them well I
wish that was true but it's not because
adults in their 20s 30s 40s 50s and even
60s still get pimples just like
teenagers and the products needed to get
it under control remains the same check
out the video description if you
struggle with acne or pimples I've added
a few good options for you that's
definitely gonna help you out anyway the
fact is whatever it causes acne or
pimples to be there for in the first
place and also helps to resolve them are
not dependent on your age
another huge myth is that H BOTS are
simply a fact of getting older is not
true even just the term age spots is
also not really accurate because uneven
skin tone and brown spots come from
years of environmental exposure at least
two enzymes in your skin's surface
causing those spots if you want to
lighten your darks part you have to use
products containing hydroquinone but if
you want to brighten your skin even more
and get an even skin tone look for
products containing Gnaeus in amide
vitamin c and certain plant extracts
like our button will have a great effect
a lot some good options for in the video
description down below but also remember
to use a good moisturizer it already
contains sunscreen if you don't you will
just get worse over time
some people say don't use a moisturizer
every day because if you do your skin is
gonna get used to it and loses its
ability to keep itself hydrated all the
time what it's not true guys it's like
saying hey you shouldn't drink so much
water every day because your body is
gonna get used to it while your body
needs it and your skin also needs help
just in a different way because over
time your skin loses its ability to stay
hydrated like it used to when you were
young and this is because of sun damage
and age and also the climate that you
live in
nothin it washing your face with a
normal bar of soap is good for your skin
no it's not the skin on your face and
the skin in your body is very different
so bars imbalance your skin's natural pH
causing dehydration and even those bars
of soap that's made for your skin is not
really good for it why because there's
ingredients that keeps the soap in that
bar form exactly the culprit of the
clogging your pores instead use a good
gentle water soluble cleanser I've added
my best options for you in a video
description that you can check out you
know of all these lies in the skincare
world maybe I should start my own
skincare brand or line where I am honest
number one make products that is very
effective and also affordable at the
same time hmm there are any companies
interested of doing something like this
with me maybe should get in contact if
you liked the video get a thumbs up
subscribe and we will talk soon
[Music]
you